VASILEVSKIY TO THE BENCH
FIVE SKATERS ON FIVE
PELECH WITH THE PUCK AND
REVERSED IT AROUND FOR BAILEY.
HELD IN BY SERGACHEV
NOW PALAT AND PELECH
DOWN TO 15 HE COULD SEE SECONDS.
PUCK OUT OF THE ZONE
SERGACHEV WITH IT FOR TAMPA BAY.
TOO FAR FOR McDONAGH
NO ICING
DOWN TO FIVE
PUCK COMES OUT TO McDONAGH AND
THE GAME ON HIS STICK.
WHAT A BLOCK IN FRONT BY PULOCK?
THE ISLANDERS WIN GAME FOUR.
WOW!
>> Brian: WOW.
THAT IS SOMETHING, ISN'T IT?
>> Eddie: RYAN McDONAGH WITH A
SPINORAMA WITH TIME EXPIRING AND
RYAN PULOCK SLIDING.
WATCH 6 IN BLUE.
HE'LL GET TO THE FRONT OF THE
NET.
THE SPIN
VARLAMOV IS OUT.
AND RYAN PULOCK SAVES TH
OF THE NIGHT
>> Brian: BIG DINNER COMING FOR
PULOCK
ON VARLAMOV, PEACE
WOW!
THAT IS UNBELIEVABLE
>> Kenny: RYAN PULOCK SCORED THE
WINNING GOAL IN GAME ONE AND
MAKES THE SAVE OF THE GAME, SAVE
OF THE SERIES IN GAME FOUR.
>> Eddie: UNBELIEVABLE
UNBELIEVABLE EFFORT.
HOW ABOUT THE PATIENCE OF
McDONAGH TO GET THAT PUCK, SPIN
AROUND, FIRE IT AND RYAN PULOC
WITH THE SAVE OF THE NIGHT,
WITHOUT QUESTION
LET'S TAKE ANOTHER LOOK AT IT.
THE SPIN, THE EMPTY NET.
OH
AND PULOCK ON ALL FOUR'S
ACROSS
IT DOESN'T GET ANY BETTER THAN
THAT
YOU JUST NEVER KNOW WHEN IT'S
YOUR TIME AND TH